i have gotten such good response from
people
it's been so much fun doing california
is the fifth
largest economy in the world it's bigger
than russia and you've got a lot to
figure out
thank you for your time today and we're
going to follow up with being our first
in-studio guest since kovit
oh thinking history history right here i
love this
dude thank you nice to see you again in
person yeah nice to see you and nice to
see both of you
what the hell well that's not the first
woman hammer has stolen from me
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
she promised that i would be first she
promised me
she's saving you for last greg damn
wheaties box
went to her head you got to work your
way up you know all right
well there's nothing funnier than
watching a media caught scrambling to
cover their messes it's like watching a
cat doing somersaults in a litter box
take cnn the conspiracy nut network
which spent four years
pushing the collusion hoax calling
anyone who disagreed with them a bigot
they flooded the media zone with
impeachment theater and anti-trump
hysteria that kept everyone busy
as the coronavirus spread their
emotional despair over trump
pushed the most destructive man-made
disaster in history into a dark
corner where it blossomed like a pot
plant and cat's bedroom window
that was a lot and when the virus took
off the media
along with the who concluded it wasn't a
lab leak
before they'd seriously even
investigated it they labeled it a loony
conspiracy theory because like the nba
they'd rather rip trump than offend
china
so now what do these clowns do when that
narrative has collapsed
you know i don't think they'd blame
trump do you and for trump
the question of the lab theory was less
about finding the truth
and more about finding a scapegoat as he
made racist comments
deflecting from his own poor political
performance
and coincided with higher rates of hate
crimes against
asian americans that sounds an awful lot
like a defensive dodge
sure yeah we were wrong but it doesn't
matter because the guy who's right is a
big
meanie but just for fun let's pretend
this is the one time cnn is right can't
a president be wrong
and the media still investigate a
legitimate story
simultaneously you follow even if their
opinion is true about trump
it doesn't explain why the media didn't
do its job
the lab league theory was more plausible
than blaming a wet market pangolin
but it was portrayed like it came from
alex jones's dream diary
that's on the news that's not on trump
now i don't claim to be edward r
murrow i'm closer to edward munster
in height and we both wear black shorts
but even as a commentator i'm way more
objective than these bitter spinsters
and i'll let you know when i'm talking
out of my butt cnn can't do that because
it's all but
all the time look look at their lineup
it's a whole lot of crack
and when i say broken i mean they're
actually broken the trump era caused an
entire news network to fall apart
like a perfectly cooked pork shoulder
or a wet burrito as you can tell
i'm hungry but at least i'm not thirsty
like this fella on the right they're all
about it why
because the more this is about china
being sneaky the less it is
about our leadership failing under trump
so the byproduct of that is what fueling
hate
toward innocent people of asian descent
you know that that's a reason why we've
had an uptick in the assaults
but it's all about the game oh my god
he really is morphing into ron burgundy
i can't blame him how dare you i know
that was bad i apologize to ron burgundy
even though he's a fictitious character
but again even if cuomo was right about
trump's intentions which he isn't it's
still
irrelevant you should still investigate
a plausible cause to the worst
medical disaster since gerald nadler's
tummy tuck
instead these bozos link the calls for
investigating the lab
to asian hate crime sorry increases in
crime came from a decrease in
accountability following the defund the
police push
no bail early releases due to covid
cities no longer prosecuting theft
unstable characters on empty streets
targeting the old and vulnerable
and cuomo thinks that has to do with
trump how long before they tell us that
trump was on the grassy knoll in dallas
how long before they tell us he killed
kurt cobain
maybe maybe chris is deflecting blame
from his brother
again but this is what happens when you
have only one tool
in the toolkit and you got a tool
operating it
what these dopes are saying is purely
based on their residual trumped
arrangement
it doesn't matter if trump was on to
something his intent was so bad
that's enough to ignore it cnn wasn't
alone other people mocked the theory
only because trump and pompeo were onto
it early
they're literally explaining to you
how media prejudice against trump bias
their coverage
because the more it's china's fault the
less they can blame trump
now i'll admit trump has said some crazy
stuff but when he was right
he was right on the bigger stuff from
the vaccines
to china in the first place to the
middle east hell to running for
president in the first place we all
laughed at that
he's got a way better track record than
our gloriously awful
and very bitter media so you want to
talk talk deflection
now we're being told that the biden
white house shut down an inquiry into
the theory
that china's bio weapon program may have
played a role in unleashing this
pandemic
why well it was launched by the biden
the trump administration
and isn't that reason enough instead
what do they want to investigate
what really went down on january 6th
yeah because the media hasn't squeezed
enough feverish content out of that
story
so rather than investigate what could
have killed millions of people
they want to relive january 6th for
their own amusement
which means if and when another lab
experiment goes bad
who can we blame then well like a
portable toilet
it's best if you don't look into it
a disgusting
[Applause]
welcome tonight's guests she puts the
rad
in radiology author of the new book
panic attack dr nicole
sapphire
he told this uber driver to only make
right turns
right turn strategies president chris
barrett
not from the spin doctors her
favorite vitamins are a c and ecstasy
fox's contributor captain
and he's a mountain of a man and well
worth the climb
my massive sidekick and a host of an
upset on fox nation
tyrus
chris i go to you first it's been a long
time buddy have you seen years i know i
know you still look the same
i don't know why you never call anymore
it's because i never really liked you
honestly
okay let me let's get to the point here
should the press eat crow
or should the crows eat the press i'm
good with either one
so what's so amazing is watching maggie
haberman on cnn this week actually
admitting
that the reason why they didn't actually
follow through and investigate whether
this
was a lab leak was because trump said it
so it became political and so therefore
of course they doubted it of course they
they railed against me and also why is
it less racist
to say that it came from a wet market in
wuhan
than it is to say that it was a lab leak
i i just
i don't understand everything trump says
is racist of course i mean at the end of
the day
all this is always about trump
for them they can't stop and i always go
back to
how doctor how they smeared the glorious
wet markets
like i you know they're they're they're
they're uh customer base just got
sliced in half much like their pangolins
that they sell i hear by the way their
pangolins are delicious
uh they eat the scales which is
something to think about
dr sapphire i don't even know where i'm
going with this are you disturbed
by the way they treated this theory as
some kind of conspiracy theory
greg i can tell you i was a target of
that media hit campaign early summer
late spring last year when i was asked
about
what are the possible origins of the
virus which is why there's an entire
chapter of it in my book because
the truth is important to people and yes
wet markets
disgusting places you have animals you
have humans and it it makes sense that's
how a lot of local outbreaks of
pathogens occur
really there is a there is a plausible
possibility there of course that
natural spillover is plausible but also
the fact that you have the wuhan
institute of virology
yes 10 miles away
and they are the leading the global
leader of coronavirus research
they also have published that they have
the most genetically similar
coronavirus that's circulating as sarsko
v2 right now so
yeah of course we're going to ask
questions but i was destroyed by the
media saying i was wrong
anti-science and everything that i was
saying was just promoting conspiracy
theories
and the response i saw they did a sort
of correction on vox would be like well
now that more information has emerged
she's not totally insane
more information has emerged right but
we've
like it's not new that as you mentioned
this
just so happened to happen the outbreak
started in and
only in the one place where there was
this
lab that had been studying bats and
coronaviruses for years
and it was so good at attacking humans
almost as if it had been engineered to
do so i mean i'm not a
scientist i'm also not a doctor like you
but like imagine if
there was like a giraffe walking around
the bronx and
he seemed really comfortable with humans
and someone was like oh maybe that's the
giraffe from the meet and greet with the
animals at the bronx
zoo like nobody would be like you
lunatic where did you where did you
think of that conspiracy theorist but
that's exactly what the media did except
they also added racist
yeah yeah no i was going to say it's
kind of like imagine in a tiny small
town
there's an a a fireworks explosion
right and they go where could it be
let's not go to the fireworks factory
absolutely not there that's not going to
the fire do you i think it happened at
the convent
you know those nuns like to hoard their
barrel bombs and bottle rackets
under their habits their nasty habits
their nasty habits tyrus what is wrong
with me
you know what is wrong okay first of all
by the way you met you talked to caitlin
today what did she ask about me
first of all just so you know i big
leagued her
big leader i was like excuse me olympian
pardon me
she was like hey tyrus i'm a huge fan
who's that uh
guy that co-host with you sometime
hammer no no gut feel yes gutfield how
is he i said he's
he's fine why are you ducking the show
you're scared and she said
yes she's nervous so she's going you
know she's going to start on the ground
up you know how it works
yes you want to get on the big show you
started hannity
[Laughter]
did you get in america's newsroom yes
then maybe you do a waters world
and at some point you get a call from
our guy yes
who says you made it yes and then you
come on i mean that's how it works
i know she wanted preferential treatment
because of the olympian and running for
governor but in the garfield show we
don't play that no we do
i don't walk all up in here and just no
i like
that our show intimidates the world's
greatest athlete like she i think she
won some olympic medals
yes but you know it's it's now it's
what's going on right now as far as
medals and awards going
although we for some reason don't
qualify for anything our numbers are
there yeah
you've got all kinds of emmys and stuff
maybe even an oscar for
me smiling at a lot of your jokes but
[Laughter]
the whole point of this whole thing was
kat uh and i usually agree with
everything
no new information was discovered
exactly
it's just true he was right and
breaking as i was walking through the
hotel there i know breaking news that
biden president biden in his wisdom has
decided yes to give you
90 days to figure this out right that's
true
even though he will not admit that the
former administration was correct
and there are assumptions and we need to
investigate it full regalia
or he'll say we'll investigate it really
good after soup
then he says 90 days which is a small
victory but let's re let's be serious at
this point any evidence that would have
been there
is gone whether it was destroyed or is
just gone they're not going to come to a
conclusion
the same clumsy guy was probably going
to do it again
you know like you know it's that first
year intern that got in because of his
uncle yeah you know and he's mixed oops
or so it's like
or or it's the nephew that you didn't
like okay to see here
yes it's like it's a nephew you don't
like you're gonna go work at the animal
viral
leak lab and then you're gonna have a
weird superpower
all right hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else